[Music]
hey welcome back to another episode on
the corridor crew today is a very
special day because we are joined by
none other than brent hello there where
are we we are at cerro gordo and back in
the 1800s this was the largest silver
mine in california's history and you
live here full time now right this is a
ghost town every day
my goal above and beyond all else is to
like understand the history here and
then preserve it for future generations
rebuilding old cabins stabilizing them
understanding old documents and that but
with you guys we'll do something totally
different so we are here today to scan
it in 3d so that we can preserve it for
you digitally forever yes brent here has
his own really cool youtube channel
documenting what it's like to actually
live here you do a very great job of
making people excited about this town
there's so many people who would love to
visit this place but the vast majority
of people will never get that
opportunity so i'm hoping that by being
able to scan this place we will give
your fans that opportunity whenever they
want that'll be awesome you know this
town has been around for 150 years 150
years from now i imagine they'll hope
that they had you know a good
representation of what each building
looked like and so if we can accomplish
that that's gonna be pretty cool we are
also joined by chris heinrich from
polycam he is here to make sure we get
some very good scans of this whole place
i'm super excited to be here with brent
and the corridor crew to be scanning
cerro gordo there is almost no better
place on earth than i can imagine to try
to scan a place and reconstruct it
digitally for the viewers of brent's
channel for anybody else who would like
to visit this place and it wouldn't be a
ghost town if we didn't have our
resident ghost expert
this guy um
i i consider myself a ghost enthusiast a
ghost lover in that i have loved many
ghosts my hope and goal today is to get
a lot of scans of all the exterior of
the buildings maybe even some interiors
of the buildings and then at the end of
the day if we got time the inside of a
mine i think that's my favorite part of
saraguru is the mines there's 30 miles
of mines underneath there 30 miles
wait i didn't realize it was 30 miles
like underneath it's like a honeycomb
right now so you're standing on top of
many many miles of mines the most common
question i get when about my time up
here is like what it's like to be in a
mine so if we can accomplish that then i
think a lot of people were stoked we
still got to figure out how to do that
we still got to actually do the scans
and that's what we're doing today so
let's get to it
what is this building we are in uh the
former general store here you know where
all the miners will get their supplies
so imagine pickaxes helmets dry goods
canned goods and these days this is kind
of the museum so anything i find here on
site goes in here anytime i go into the
mine and find something it goes back
there what are some of the more special
items in here like obviously i'm looking
at dynamite boxes yeah so the classic
find in an abandoned mine is dynamite
boxes because all of the mining was done
here with dynamite fire in the hole
[Music]
this is what they were mining at cerro
gordo this is galena you won't realize
how heavy this is but you know if you
want to feel it's
galena so galena is a lot of lead and a
little bit of silver so don't lick it
don't do it don't do it
don't run put it down put the lead down
and so back in the day they mined close
to if you dressed for inflation 500
million dollars with this this is how
they would mine before they had big
machinery here this would be called
single jacking so what they do is they
go up to the rock put it in hit it do a
quarter turn hit it do a quarter turn
you would get this far in you take a
stick of dynamite put it in that hole
cover it up blow it up if you don't have
the resources to have an automatic hoist
you put it in a bag like this and you
have to put this over your shoulder and
like hike the ore out of the mine to
then refine it you want to start with
that hammer
yes i found this hammer in a mine and
you can see how hard this guy was
working it kind of like flattened where
his hand was hitting it but i would love
to
scan this and i have no idea what i'm
doing with the app so so do you want to
just do like a super quick tutorial for
these guys they haven't done it before i
wish i knew some of the finer details or
perhaps tips and tricks on how to get
those sweet sweet scans
but what he said
following along at home you could
download polycam if you've got an iphone
if you don't have an iphone we're
launching a way that you can upload your
images to our website and process them
there so you can take images with any
camera that you've got the reason why i
love polycam so much is that for years
we've been doing 3d scanning
photogrametry and it's been such like a
complex thing to do but polycam has made
it so easy that you can literally whip
out your phone and do it and it just
does the work for you if you've got a
newer iphone then you have lidar
available to you but what we're going to
use is photo mode which works on all the
iphones and it's also the best at
scanning small objects i think a good
way for beginners to get started is to
take some smallish object ideally
something that's interesting visually
interesting something important to you
and try to find you know something like
a white surface that we're going to scan
it again scan it from all angles and the
algorithm is going to stitch it together
into one coherent 3d model for best
practices you want to have as much like
ambient lighting as possible because
whatever lighting you get in your scan
is baked in that is now going to be part
of the actual visual texture so i think
one way that works really well is just
to be outside in the shade what i'm
really interested in is everything is
like if you look
there's some type of stamp in here i
think it says
nevada over here and behind it i think
it's initials so i'm wondering if the
guy like stamped his initials into it
so if we can preserve even like the
finer details like that
that would be sweet then yeah you should
be good to go you can hit upload and
process you can check back you know 10
minutes or so and so one piece of cereal
history preserved
a couple million to go but we'll get
there yeah
we'll get it done
they can stand really well
look at how good that can scale wow look
at that candy wow that's awesome what's
going on
dude that is you did the photo move
that's fantastic dude yeah that's a can
as far as for scan goes
solid for scale yeah hey
aced my first scan the great thing about
scanning is that you can scan pretty
much anything right and so we're going
to scan individual artifacts here but
also scan the entirety of this room the
point of the light art is to basically
just scan the environment in 3d but then
polycam takes that and actually projects
the images that your phone is capturing
onto that geometry it's like real-time
projection mapping and what's nice about
the lidar mode is it actually kind of
gives you a real-time
feedback of what is being scanned
whereas the photo mode even though it's
really great and whatnot you're kind of
just guessing and you'll find out later
whether or not it worked it's so cool to
see a real time like 3d model of the
environment as you're looking at it it's
very satisfying the thing about 3d
scanning is it can be as detailed as you
want the more input data you capture
the better your scans are going to be
it's one thing to 3d scan a room that's
just a room but it's another to 3d scan
something where pretty much every single
item in the room
has just a stupid amount of detail 3d
scanning is a time intensive process but
fortunately polycam does make it
relatively quick and i think we're going
to get fairly comparable quality i'm
looking at just like the raw geometry
simplified scan of it just so you have
like a preview but for this since it's a
space i'm just going to hit the space
preset and hit process it's going to
take about three minutes to process this
directly on my phone i don't have to
upload the photos to a server to process
all right brent you want to see the
first so this is just the lidar scan
this is a super quick scan that i did oh
wow and this is within the app yeah this
is all still inside of polycam and this
is just with the lidar scan so if we
wanted to get more detail we can use
photo mode i know that i mean already
that's amazing but it's kind of cool
just to like literally rock around yeah
and seeing it in the very space he's
standing yes
super surreal about like the scale yet
[Music]
are you scanning the scan i'm not
scanning the scan but i'm looking at the
scan inside of this scanned room this is
pretty crazy to see you're like the size
of the whole
you're now you're a legit giant and it's
like actually doing like a live
rotoscoping of you that's pretty crazy
welcome to the general store
yeah so this is a good example of what
you can do with an interior but chris
actually did a scan of this entire town
before the sun hit it which means that
everything is in shadow which means
everything is very ambiently and
uniformly lit so we can re-light it in
cg yes we're trying to scan the town
we're trying to scan inside these
buildings but i think i have to get one
scan
of you
yeah yeah exactly
we gotta preserve you you are part of
the history of this town now we gotta
preserve you as well so we got the quick
scan in here you're gonna do a photo
scan at a higher detail inside here
while i get the drone up in the air and
do just a scan of the entire town with a
high noon sun sounds good i'm excited
i think i'm going to try to do a scan
that is basically the entire valley here
and then i'm going to follow that up
with a lot of scans of individual
buildings so i'll try to get it at
multiple different levels so i can do it
from multiple different angles basically
wherever you're scanning from is where
it's going to look best in the final 3d
model so if you're doing a lot of really
high aerial photography the scans will
look great from up there but maybe not
so much from down here so i think i'll
probably try to fly this drone lower and
just kind of be very cognizant of where
it actually is so the amount of images
you need you know depends on the
complexity of your object and so you
know it's a thing that you kind of get a
sense for and then we have a cool
officer we have detail reduced medium
full right so depending on your
application you can select different
levels of detail since we're doing
historical preservation here we want to
preserve as much detail as possible so
go ahead and select full done
it's going
so we're up here at the main entrance of
the union mine and i'm gonna get the
drone up in the air so i can scan the
actual building here from the outside
i'm gonna have to be very careful not to
hit the power lines and just try to get
as much coverage as i can and so while
i'm doing that the other guys will
actually be inside this is the actual
shaft of the union mine so this hole
goes 900 feet straight down and then
every 150 or 200 feet there's levels the
way you go down is this cable slowly
lowers this cage this is where all the
ore came out of so this cage saw a lot
of action back in the day still works
caleb goes up and then over there to
that spool and the guy sitting in that
spool is basically like has your life in
his hands you know need be he's gonna
pull on this to try to make it stop and
what he's looking at is that dial up
there that's how far down the cage is so
this is a retrofitted hoist obviously
this hydraulic system wasn't from the
1800s and neither was the electricity so
that used to be powered by steam that
required that big you know boiler over
there i'm not going to lie there is you
can feel about you can feel the
so there is a spooky element to this
where it's like
what if you know
two drones in the air right now yeah
we're just trying to capture as many
scans as we can before we lose light so
chris has his drone up in the air i've
got my drone up in the air this has been
a really awesome day 3d scanning one
wheeling flying drones
i think it's going to turn out well
so this is by no means necessary for
typical scanning but if you want to get
like really into it this is a rig this
we built with the intention of going
through the actual
mines
we're going to go
into a mine and uh old silver mine and
hopefully make it so other people can go
into a mine albeit digitally this is
cobbled together from a whole bunch of
random things this is very much so a
frankenstein rig but it's going to be
very bright the cool thing they think
about is you got to think when this rig
is engaged this will be the brightest
that mine has ever been you know back in
the day they didn't have crazy bright
lights they're using carbide or candles
and so we may see things that nobody
else before has seen you know take it
easy but dangerous um we are going to
i mean i don't even know
[Music]
just leading the way on a one wheel
let me show you my mine
oh my gosh this is so cool dude this is
radical whoa thank god i got a helmet
this is nuts brent yeah this is so cool
oh there's a little room back here
oh that mannequin is terrifying
i'm not gonna lie to you thank you for
not telling me about that because
for a half a second i was like it's real
it's finally happening
yep if you don't lean too far back if
you look behind you oh what the [ __ ] oh
my gosh dude how far down does that go
uh
about 150 feet
back in the day this connected into the
union mine all underground so you would
have been able to go from down there all
the way to where we were before what was
that
how likely
is it that there's a bell witch around a
bell witch is a particular kind of witch
something to do with the town bell and a
witch that eats children yeah fun yeah
yeah that common record okay so we got
to watch is that one
cold guys
dead eyes oh you got some some golf down
here yeah we got some golf you know we
got a little bit of this little bit of
that anybody want to put a hole in one
right now
[Music]
you know
i think the ghost kind of blocked it
yeah so people have scanned caves i
don't know about mines i mean we may be
in uncharted territory here on
territory
but i mean i think one of the cool
things about scanning the mine is if you
come in here with a flashlight or
carbide light or whatnot you kind of
only see one spot at a time the thing
that's illuminated but with this
lighting rig we're gonna be able to
light up the entire thing so you're
gonna be able to see it all lit up in a
way that you just couldn't see it
otherwise would you recommend lidar for
this yeah what's kind of cool about the
lidar mode is it actually uses the
accelerometer so that is another way for
it besides just recognizing the visual
patterns to kind of keep track of how
far you've gone i'm just gonna start by
scanning at the end through here and
then just kind of just work our way back
until we get to the entrance of this
whole line this is going to be a very
slow going thing kind of trying to just
corkscrew because all these rocks have
like back faces front faces i want to be
able to just
get all of that
back here bad scam oh yeah there it is
cute
oh
i am glad you're so glad i'm wearing a
helmet dude i feel more head trauma
danger in this mine than i do one
wheeling
tell you what though i think putting
this many lights on it was a good idea
everything is looking crispy
how you feeling
miners must have very strong fats
they're smaller they they were they were
minor yeah very much boom
you're almost there man the others
inside the battery you got that uh i've
got a battery on me it's okay i'm almost
done you got this you're so close he's
at the end
i think we are just now finishing hold
again we're done
[Music]
you did it save it before the phone dies
oh my god my phone is at
three percent battery so i got so many
rocks in my hair and down my shirt story
of my life not the hair business but the
rocks everywhere yeah i know
that was amazing whoa
this one came out great so we got the
data oh you explored further than i did
down that hole i stopped at the hole but
you went around and kept going yeah i
know what you mean because i was like
that's a scary hole i'm not going
further yeah yeah i know you see all the
timbering in there too that's cool yeah
like a little dingus yeah this rig
worked out really well there's so much
light that everything was at a high
enough exposure that as i'm moving
around there was no motion blur
and so like all the textures are really
crisp and it was bright enough that like
when i wasn't close enough to the walls
it was still exposing it well enough as
a super janky last minute build i think
it works really well
um who wants some chicken meal on this
side i do also a beer so after a couple
days of scanning we had everything we
needed brent thank you so much for
having me thank you guys i'm super
excited i have a new uh hobby or
addiction depending on it of scanning
things so thank you great you guys i'm
excited to see the results i'm gonna
keep doing it and uh you know they say
how do you eat an elephant one bite at a
time so i'll just one artifact at a time
serogordo will be preserved there you go
yeah i'll make it happen the next plan
of action for this video is to get those
scans ready to go get them in a state
that we can share them with the world
yeah but first things first you gotta
get off this mountain so of course we
one wheeled down the whole thing it was
a waste too it took us like an hour to
get down and fortunately none of us got
hurt especially nick not hurt at all
i hit one rock recovered and then before
i could rebalance i hit another rock on
the other side
and uh yeah ate [ __ ] but i rolled out of
it and
[Music]
no injuries
so we're basically just kind of going
through and cataloging all of the scans
we got the same way you would catalog
artifacts in a museum chris and his team
are actually going through and creating
a landing page for all of these assets
and whatnot i liked this skin in
particular because it's just like it's
got a lot of crazy decent i mean look at
the back side of this tree this is nuts
i have never experienced this level of
quality from a photo scan so easily
attainable but why i'm really excited is
all of the drone scans that we got but i
thought this is an iphone app well you
were right it's also now other things
because polycam is launching a feature
today where you can actually upload any
photos you want to their website i'll
show you how easy it is to get a 3d scan
as long as you've like taken pictures
from pretty much every angle go up to
create new like that hit the little
photo icon in the top corner and then
you just uh select all your photos that
you want like anywhere between like one
and two hundred images for an object is
usually pretty good hit open it loads
them all up right here see i selected
120. i usually do the full detail and
i'll turn on object masking yeah and
then you just hit upload and process you
wait for it to upload it takes a little
bit of time because you gotta wait to
upload your photos wait for it to
process and then re-download but it's so
effortless that it doesn't feel like it
takes time one of the things i really
wanted to do was to take these scans and
combine them into one central scan of
the whole town the reason why being able
to use any camera images is exciting
because it opens up more than just using
actual physical cameras earth studio is
awesome i've used it before for a lot of
the scale videos that i've made and just
by simply rendering out an orbiting
camera around the saragordo mountain
range itself i was able to take those
images from that sequence upload it into
the scan here and look at that dude the
entire mountain range so the reason why
that's cool is that now i have the scan
of the whole mountain it's got all the
geometry and color i can now scale that
up and fit it into place like lego
blocks with the smaller more high
detailed scan of the whole town and then
combine that with this even smaller and
even more detailed scans of the
individual buildings and that's exactly
what i've done here so it took some
effort to kind of like line things up
with the scale position and orientation
but once you did it like it works pretty
well
each color here represents an individual
separate scan that i've combined
together and while i was doing this i
realized oh no we didn't get a scan of
the hillside between the town and the
mine up here
we're just gonna have an earth studio
render which is not supposed to be good
enough at this scale that's why we're
supposed to replace it but we didn't
have the hill we only had part of the
hill here then i remembered i was flying
fpv while standing up on that hillside
there so i should have gotten enough
frames in the video footage i grabbed
the video i sped it up like 500 so i
didn't have to use as many frames
rendered out around 200 of them threw it
into polycam and then suddenly i had an
incredible scan of this whole hill this
is this is really cool chris is going to
be in any minute now so it's time for us
to show brent
what we've made
hello yo what up dude man pretty much
hey guys dude good to see you man how's
it going it's going pretty good so we've
been hard at work getting all of the
scans that we got out there at saragordo
prepared and put together and chris and
his team have actually prepared a really
cool landing page on their website
that'll act as like a really cool
depository for all of the scans that
already exist and may eventually exist
all right i'm excited let's do it
this page is something that's going to
be kind of up on the internet forever
now as like part of the living record of
sarah gordo where fans of cerro gordo
everywhere to be able to kind of explore
and enjoy and help help to continue
preserve i mean my hope is that this is
something that kind of continues to grow
over time and becomes a better and
better record for posterity if anyone
can visit this page right now and as we
scroll down we'll start seeing some of
these scans
oh dude yeah the union mine all you have
to do is just click one of these and
it'll open it up in a 3d viewer inside
of your browser
and just like that we have the whole
scan
and it's pretty high quality like we can
get in here and
hey
that is awesome i took my time to fly my
drone as closely and slowly around this
entire place so this is just one of the
many scans that we got so cool this is
exciting for me like my main goal always
is to you know preserve the history here
and this is like doing it in a way that
i never even thought was possible not
only is this possible it's getting
easier by the day this scan came out
pretty dang good like each of these
separate scans are are viewable
separately as their own thing but i
actually went through and combined all
of them into one giant scan here
so this isn't something that's on the
website currently because it's a little
too complex we're gonna have to optimize
it if we want this to be uh viewable but
it'll be great for like renders and
stuff but as you can see here it's the
whole town and high quality scans of
each of these places here i mean the
fact that the scan was able to get like
the individual trusses of this whole
thing working and of course we got the
union mine up here and the whole
hillside here
so this is huge that's crazy
so there's one more thing that we got
put together here we also scanned a mine
and you might remember i had to do it in
several different sections we're able to
combine those sections together after
the fact
and that is this
so this is the whole scan there and if
we get really close up
[Music]
there you are
back at the mini golf course so we've
got the whole thing put together and
what's great about the 3d scanning is
that it's able to kind of keep track of
the scale of things so we now know
exactly how long this tunnel goes this
is where like miners would have gone to
work pretty much every day this was the
safeguard tunnel so back in the day this
connected to the union mines the largest
mine here i don't know that any miner or
anybody has been able to visualize a
mine in this way you know how long is it
it is about 570 feet long okay okay
there's 30 miles of mine underneath the
town so obviously a stretch ambitious
goal would be to slowly over many many
deers take my polycam down there and try
to capture it all just even like a
generational thing they don't even mind
like this anymore so you know like even
beyond that the experience of walking
through abandoned hard rock mines is
something that won't last forever and so
it's very cool to be able to preserve it
in this way yeah we learned a lot from
this whole process because i had never
scanned a tunnel before let alone a
silver mine we were able to get this
exported out and load it onto my phone
and load it up in ar so you can like
load this out in front of your house and
uh walk through the mine but we also got
you know some of the actual artifacts
you know this one was cool because you
could really see the decaying chunky
debris of the wood itself
like
the fact that i was able to get the
quality of that you know and now now
that it's digital like this is preserved
forever so you remember scanning that
hammer
yep here it is and there it is yeah dang
yeah it's so cool just i mean you can
see the groove where the guy was using
it so often on the handle oh that's
right yeah here see where he's like
swinging that over and over and over oh
that's right his initials
and there they are
yeah that's something i just can't relay
in a video you know but this is now
something that all your viewers can
literally open up on their own computer
now like they can they can kind of look
at this and also what's cool is that
like in the future if you ever find any
new artifacts you can actually continue
to scan them and put them on this page
you know like it's kind of a 3d museum
of these things that they could pull out
of their minds it's cool that all of
your viewers will be able to visit this
webpage see all these different scans
but it's another story to kind of
interact with the scans in a more
visceral tangible way maybe with their
friends maybe with you so i want you to
go to this webpage real quick go down to
the union mine here just below the
actual link for the scan you see hubs by
mozilla click that link and i'm going to
click it on mine as well
[Laughter]
so basically what chris and his team has
done is they've assembled these scans
into a multiplayer experience that
anyone can visit in their web browser
wow you can look around you can use the
wasd to kind of steer yourself around up
to 50 people can join this room at the
same time we got hubs set up for at
least like five or six of the the spaces
on the website so for like the museum
for the assay building for the whole
town one of the whole town scans here i
think i can uh i can do something real
quick i'm gonna set up a camera i'm
gonna get a little uh selfie with you
here check this out here stand right
next to me over here
there we go so now we can look up at
this camera here
three two one smile
[Music]
yeah this is cool i'm this is this is
really cool like i'm just very very
happy that this worked out like we
talked about doing this and the fact
that it's here working
is nuts
i really feel like this is just the
start i'm very excited about where this
could go and all the scans that you'll
be able to continue getting i had no
idea what it would become and so this is
super cool we're gonna have a link to
all of this in the description of our
videos so all of your viewers if they're
interested they can check this out no it
worked out amazingly and to see it being
used in the second historical
preservation is this something that i
didn't know about you know and i'm
excited to
continue scanning and preserving and
seeing where this thing can go building
the digital museum of sarah gordo
cool man well hey it was great seeing
you again and uh yeah i'd love to hang
out again soon
yeah sounds good thanks guys
thank you so much to brent for hosting
us episode he's got a whole youtube
channel he lives in this place full time
and he posts videos every week link in
the description for him also polycam is
amazing i've literally been obsessed
scanning everything i've been doing a
scan a day i swear oh my god you can
check them out links in the description
it's an iphone app but also you can sign
up for their web services now and you
can upload from any camera it's pretty
great i highly recommend it but thank
you so much for watching and i will see
you next week in a react video and
whatever we got coming out next week is
something right
see you then thanks